so
how can guys spot i mean should we move
on to the next question so how can guys
spot an alpha widow
yeah so i mean it's
it's she's pining for somebody pretty
much and
it also shows up on how she's
how she's making this guy your current
so she's dating you she making you
qualified to her or she qualifying to
you is she trying to earn
you after a point or is she trying to
get you to
is she showing up a bit entitled and
trying to get you to earn her
and a lot of guys fall into that you
know
that paradigm of trying to earn a chick
you know that's what they try to do they
try to you know i'm gonna do things for
her i'm going to
buy her nice things take her nice place
with my lady right they try to win over
this woman
and if she's you know making you making
you wait for sex for example
like a lot of these things are good
signs but you with social media nowadays
you can look at that
as evidence it's pretty good evidence
because
she will keep photos around she will
keep
relationships going and you'll see that
stuff show up on social media
with these exes and i just you know the
example of that post that you put
in the community a couple weeks ago um
can you
just kind of break it down because i
also responded to that as well with a
bunch of the other guys you want to deal
with that
yeah yeah i don't know which one we're
doing which come up like we were talking
about the one
where there was uh photographs of some
x's
and like how would you handle it oh yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yep yeah so i mean
so it's interesting because i need to
back this up in a little bit
for guys need to understand that women
are deceptive by nature no
i know crazy no crazy but
wait let me get a pen let me write this
down wait
yes and are deceptive by
nature write that [ __ ] down believe it
or not they're deceptive by nature
and this is not just like oh you're just
being negative on women
no no no no okay as a man my nature is
to use
aggression violence and anger at certain
points to get things done
i don't do that though because we have a
set of societal rules
and i have a forebrain and a front in a
frontal lobe that dictates
dictates my behavior but men will use
aggression intimidation
right that's something that we are wired
to do well women being the weaker
sex physically weaker can't use that
kind of intimidation usually
so they evolve to use deception
manipulation
they're wired to lie the
studies have been done and attraction
studies have
shown that women by and large lie even
to themselves
about what attracts them to someone
which is why
generally it's bad to get advice from
women on relationships and attraction
because they're going to tell you
a set of things that they think they
like but really
they're responding to a whole different
set of things
they don't actually know and they're
deceptive to themselves and it makes
sense i mean i'm not again it's not
trying to be
just crap all over women but think about
it even like
in afghanistan today if a woman was
honest about her sexual desires and
proclivities
she'd get stoned to death she'd be
killed she'd have acid thrown on her
face right so
so being the weaker sex they've had to
use deception
you know it's part of survival so we
can't get mad about it but you have to
recognize
what it is and so they're
going to hold on to these sexual
experiences
and these people of their past until
somebody comes
in and basically replaces all of that
you know right right so her pergamus
mind requires the best
for her to have the best once the if
you're her best and you come along
these other things of her past won't
even be a thought anymore
so when that ex-boyfriend that was her
sexual best at one point
who you know he he contacts her maybe
every year to see what she's up to
and all that and she doesn't respond to
that message
and forgets that message usually w-w-id
what you do you do what you're doing you
know but it could be like you know but
it's just like hey what you've been up
to you haven't talked to
all that crap right it's like if you
guys ever really hung out platonically
let's be real
you know what i mean and so you know and
this guys will do that when they're in
relationships with women right i mean
guys
do stuff like that all the time and so
you know she
is she respond if she forgets to respond
to that dude and goes home like you know
what
this dude can't even respond to that guy
because she totally forgot because she's
with you
that's a good sign right you just you
just replaced all that stuff
but if she is making sure that she is
really keeping up on these relationships
and
you know and she's not keeping a healthy
boundary
like oh well we're just friends we're
going to hang out you know what i mean
that kind of stuff
and then did you ever hear that one
liner like nobody [ __ ] more
friends or sorry nobody [ __ ] more
girlfriends and wives than
just a friend so that's true
shout out to john from modern life
dating by the way and also
to new channel member matthew clements
that join button over by this
subscribe button if you're on youtube it
just lets you into the live chat
i also sort and organize comments on all
my videos and i respond to channel
members all the time too so
sorry paul here yeah no all right and so
here's this
introduces this idea too i just did a
video on this and we'll summarize some
of the key points here because it's
important
we don't talk about this actually much
and we should just like jealousy we had
that video on jealousy you guys need to
go back and watch the thing on jealousy
too
this all ties together you know um but
i'm talking about
cucking all right so you got traditional
cuckoldry
is where a woman has sex with another
guy
gets pregnant by that guy then has her
relationship guy take care of the baby
well that's strategic pluralism in a
sense
you know conception baked into it just
in the side there right and she and so
that i mean that has a
name for it in evolutionary psych and
has been studying in
the animal kingdom as well as with
humans for a reason because
it is a part of our dna it's part of her
dna to do that
so that level of deception to go get
pregnant you know
in fact her body is designed in fact to
deceive you where like chimpanzees when
they're in estrus
their you know genitals swell and you
know the other chimpanzees know
that she's ovulating with women you can
only tell if you're really good right
yeah the makeup cues yeah she's got the
giant hoopity-hoop earrings
right that's when you can tell the
bigger the hoop
so
[Laughter]
so yeah and so you know we can you know
we can sort of tell but rick her
is not overtly obvious that she's
ovulating there's a reason for that
because her body's even designed
for her to be deceptive and to conceal
those things and
again there are survival reasons for
that survival reasons for babies like
infanticide and stuff like that's a real
it was a real issue
so you know she's designed to to be
deceptive and
here's where cucking so cucking is more
of a modern term
off based off a cuckoldery but it's
basically where she
fantasizes about another guy or
acts on that fantasy so actually has sex
sexual you know stuff with that guy
um but it's not just about the sex of
that guy
it's about the degradation of her
current partner
so she's degrading that partner she gets
off
more she gets more aroused and excited
because of the deception and because it
degrades
that other man now have you ever had a
chick dropped off at your house
from the date that she was already like
the date that she's yeah of course
any guy that's out there that's been in
this hot seat would know this as well
what it's like when a chick arrives at
your house when she's on a date with
another guy she doesn't sleep with him
she doesn't do anything with him but use
him for his time or his attention or for
dinner or something like that
sometimes he's a sugar daddy but he'll
drop her off at your house like
this is the exact example that i wanted
to illustrate here for that
yeah so we want to talk practical
examples um i'll get into my
embarrassing history as a chad who
didn't care
long time ago right um i didn't care for
a while i
i didn't care about like i banged
married women at bang women who were in
relationships
didn't give a crap i don't recommend
that route but i did that route for
a while and these women are just
ruthless and they're and they enjoy
like degrading their partners they would
degrade their partners
to me you know while i'm having sex with
them
they there were times that a guy
all right this is a little embarrassing
but i don't care we're gonna say it and
people are gonna watch your show and hit
likes
so i i've had i've had
in a sexual situation the boyfriend call
me take the phone hit answer grab her
hair make her talk to the boyfriend
while i was doing stuff to her we'll say
right
guess how hard oh guess how hard those
orgasms were
yeah real hard real hard
okay so it's in in now now of course the
residual effects it's like
i you know in long-term relationships
well now you have to deal with the fact
that you've alpha widowed this trick
oh no like this is terrible like yeah in
hindsight i'm like man this is really
bad right but
this is this is her choice it wasn't me
doing it it would be you know it wasn't
me
chad doing it it's tyrone or but i mean
you guys will meet on the dating app
next week and be like wow she seems
really swell
you know she's a really kind person
right
yeah same check paul was with you know i
was just with her and she was answering
the phone she was texting you
i'll wear it together no but yeah and so
when you see that and you experience
that you're like
where is this coming from it's a primal
thing yeah
so so here's yeah and so here's where
where it comes from she needs a guy
that's
that you want that genetically superior
guy well when she settles for someone
else
she doesn't know she's always settling
because women don't think
about their decisions they don't they're
just reacting emotionally into high
brain drives
so when they're women rational paul
that's sarcasm by the way i don't i'm
looking waiting for the rational woman
to come out yeah but uh the uh yeah so
no when it comes to sexual decisions no
they're complete idiots and
i'm sorry it's true and women watching
this just recognize
that's true and then you can work with
it you know and i mean if you try to
fight it it's just a mess
so anyway they you know they
end up in the honeymoon phase they have
all the happy chemicals
and they're really living off of hope i
mean if you cornered them and were like
is the sex with you know billy here that
you're with really as good as it was
with tyrone five years ago she's gonna
be like
well no not really but you know then
she'll rationalize it but it's not
everything and he's a good guy
like she'll rationalize it during the
honeymoon phase and really
she hopes she hopes that little billy
will be a tyrone
in six months to a year maybe she can
train him or whatever you know women
will
they make that compromise let me ask you
this question how many times you get an
email or a dm or a comment from a woman
saying something along the lines of how
do i make my boyfriend more alpha
yeah all the time right all the time all
the time
and they want to send their guy to
coaching for me all that stuff
absolutely
and that's cool i mean actually that's
fine but
i want him to become more alpha but not
so alpha that he realizes that his value
is higher than me so i don't want him to
learn too much
let's not get him too you know yeah
exactly let's not get him right off the
plantation let's just partially take him
off
right still need him to plowers for me i
just need to let me go for girls night
out once a month is that cool
and so yeah yeah and so i mean
it's you know my train of thought but i
mean
they once they that honeymoon phase
wears off
they resent that guy see that women
don't just
they're not just unattracted to betas
they
they love them but hate them yeah yeah
because they it
that represents if they accidentally
have a baby with this guy right
that represents a drain on resources for
the tribe
in primal times okay well there's also
that sexy sexy sons theory too
right yeah exactly that's why there's
women that will go for the alpha seed
and then
the guy and turn him into baiting me
there's so many single mom i mean
my entire twitter feed could basically
be distilled down to
snapshots of bumble and twitter pictures
guys send me in my dms to post on there
of like pregnant single mommies that are
23 with with six kids already like you
know looking for some guy to raise the
other dudes
that's a brew of children yep
you